lutter contre les offres basse à
valoriser l'apprentissage maintenir le
soutien financier
voici trois des dix propositions que la
fédération française du bâtiment veut
mettre en avant avec l'inquiétude une
baisse de budget lié notamment à celle
des dotations des communes entraînant
donc la diminution des marchés la part
des investissements en travaux de
bâtiment a été de l'ordre de 20 % dans
le budget précédent
je saurais pas vous donner le chiffre en
grandeur donc c'est tout de même quelque
chose l'important est encore une fois vu
nombre d'entreprises yvelinoise travail
au conseil général pour l'année 2014 le
budget s'élevait à 1,2 milliard d'euros
dans les yvelines le bâtiment représente
6800 entreprises dont 3000 sont des
artisans
moi je travaille beaucoup sur les
églises et bâtiments anciens pour les
municipalités donc et maintenant le
sommes obligés de trouver des marchés
alors la crise assad de bien c'est que
le particulier se recentre et un peu
plus sur son immobilier ce qui lui
permet de faire des travaux de
rénovation quand il le peut selon la
fédération près de cent mille emplois
ont été perdus depuis 2008
en face d'eux quatre candidats aux
élections départementales pour répondre
aux inquiétudes des professionnels
il ya aussi des équipements publics qui
sont dans les compétences du conseil
départemental est donc là il ya aussi à
la fois à construire à rénover à rendre
accessible et cetera et donc c'est avec
les entrepreneurs du bâtiment qu'il faut
travailler moi même je vois année après
année que notre niveau d'investissement
que nous faisons tout pour maintenir et
quand même sensiblement moins grande
qu'elle ne l'a été
donc à partir de là je suis assez bien
placé pour comprendre que tous les
marchés que nous ne passons pas c'est
autant de travail que nous ne donnons
pas aux entreprises nous avons au front
national beaucoup d'entrepreneurs nous
avons toujours défendu au front national
la petite entreprise de défense des pme
des pénis un point essentiel de notre
programme ça c'est la vie la vitalité
d'un pays conseil général
allez et un moteur quand il ya des
subventions pour les communes il ya des
travaux faits par les communes avec
l'argent des communes mais aussi avec
une aide du département donc quelque
part ça fait des travaux importants pour
les entreprises et la construction
paroles de soutien à la filière constat
de la situation mais pas vraiment de
solutions apportées difficile en effet
de faire des propositions en la matière
quand on sait que la principale
compétence du conseil général
ce n'est pas la construction mais le
social et que les investissements en
travaux des collectivités sont soumis au
code des marchés publics et ne peuvent
pas favorisé des entreprises d'un
secteur géographique
la fédération du bâtiment des yvelines
compte 1200 adhérents